Learner B1: الخير والغبور.
Learner B1: هل تسمعني.
Learner B6: كله بخير؟ الحمد لله.
Learner B1: الحمد لله رب العالمين برك.
Learner B6: والله بخير والله الحمد لله.
Learner B1: باهي
Learner B4: الله أكبر.
Learner B4: هل هو هل هل
Learner B4: لسبب لك.
Learner B1: أي حاجة عن التوبيك أو أي حاجة نشتغل عليها صح.
Learner B4: ده سؤالي برضه مش عارفة أنا شايفة كل نيوت وإحنا ساكتة بس.
Learner B1: مش عارف حد في حد تاني يخش ولا محدش حد حيكون معانا ثاني ولا لأ.
Learner B6: مش منظم مش مدريتور.
Learner B1: ما.
Learner B6: بقول لحضرتك المنظم أو.
Learner B1: ال أنا.
Learner B6: أوكي.
Learner B4: مندور على مديرية.
Learner B6: صح.
Learner B1: فنتعرف على بعض وعمالنا.
Learner B1: أنا عادل الهندري متخرج من القاهرة متخرج 20 اشتغلت شوية واشتغلت شوية ومصر إنتو غبركم.
Learner B4: عظيم جدا خليني أديك بريس كده وأسألك كم سؤال لو ما عندكش مانع.
Learner B1: ما فيش مشكلة.
Learner B4: أنا خريجة 2,000 وتسعتعشر الإسكندرية ويعملي شغله. كله بيزنس و بيزنس حاجات زي كده
Learner B4: السؤال انت ألريدي اشتغلت حاجات ألريدي سوني إكسبيرينس.
Learner B1: والله أنا جاية علشان يعني أدوات مخابرتية أشتغل على مشروع يعني جديد يعني برضه يعني السوق ما عارفيها شوية
Learner B1: فقلت لو ركنت شوية أنسى فقلت آخذال ما يعني يكون في فرصة موجودة.
Learner B4: لا ان شاء الله يكون خير كويس.
Learner B1: خريجة
Learner B4: حد حابب يقول أي حاجة يا محمد أنا خريجة تجارة الإسكندرية.
Learner B1: وأنا نروح نعرف.
Learner B6: ممكن. أنا أعرف بنفسي.
Learner B6: تمام انا اسف انا اسف انا اسف خليفه خريج السنه دي الفين و26
Learner B6: كنت خدت يعني في كذا مكان كا
Learner B6: بي تو بي سيز و برودكت أونر وخطيب بروجرام من شركة دي لايت كنت موجود برضو في
Learner B6: هواوي لمدة سنتين السنتين. باستور
Learner B6: برضه كنت موجود برضه في تي آي سي اللي هي تبعها دي لها علاقة بال.
Learner B4: من.
Learner B6: هذا
Learner B6: فأنا يعني وطبعا كان في شوية تبع يعني داخل يعني من سنة ثالثة وأنا مهتم وأحضر إني أكمل فيه مش حابب أنا أكمل
Learner B6: بس كنت عملت كده بروجكت بقى لها علاقة يعني لها علاقة. وهكذا.
Learner B4: كفاية.
Learner B4: أهلا بيكي.
Learner B6: أهلا.
Learner B4: ما فيش حد دخل لا فيش حضرتك هنا يعني.
Learner B6: معلش. أنا بقول لحضرتك في كل وقت.
Learner B1: مخرج.
Learner B4: ، انا هبعتلهم ايميل دلوقتي اشوف إيه الدنين انت الحمد لله رضا عليك.
Learner B4: هو حد معلش فتح معاه قررت.
Learner B1: فتح أي معلش.
Learner B4: إحنا صرلنا على أير تابل.
Learner B1: لحظة لحظة.
Learner B6: بعث لي.
Learner B1: فتح معي.
Learner B6: بصراحة.
Learner B1: أنت فتحتيه أو مش عارفة تفتحيه وانا انفتح معايا بس.
Learner B4: أنا فتحته. وعملتو بس السبسي وجيت أعمل كملب قالي.
Learner B1: إيه روحي لنفس اللينك اللي هم بعتهولك في الأول خالص
Learner B1: اللي هو كان جاي من مين
Learner B1: اللي هو من الإيميل دا أنا بعثت في الشيك
Learner B1: إمم بعد ما عملت هتلاقيه بقى ادخلي على الميل ده و.
Learner B4: أم.
Learner B1: ولسه أكدت يدخلك عن ال الموضوع بس مش علاقة بالموضوع يعني.
Learner B4: المقرب.
Learner B4: لما نشوف نحن.
Learner B1: بارد.
Learner B4: تفضلي يا.
Learner B1: هو أعتقد فايدة البتاع ده حاجة أشبه بجيرة يعني.
Learner B4: فرنش.
Learner B1: بالظبط يعني هو الموجود إمم.
Learner B6: معلش مهندس عادل ممكن تكلمنا أكثر عن يعني عبال ما هم أستفيد من قبضتك يعني.
Learner B1: من غير مهندس عيني خالص الصدق. ما كنش واضح قبل ما أجاوبش المهندس.
Learner B6: كنت بتقول إن إنت إشتغلت قبل كده كبيزنس أناليز و برودكت أول كان شغال فين وجبتها ازاي يعني
Learner B6: تفاصيل كده.
Learner B1: لو جبت آخذ كورصة على اليوتيوب
Learner B1: بعد كده كنت مقدم كثير وما زلت مقدم يتيمي
Learner B1: اشتغلت في كبريت والشركة اسمها إي وورك
Learner B1: كان بقى التفاصيل مثلا أو الشغل اللي كنت بعملوه مثلا كنت بعمل درس طوري
Learner B1: ده يعني الشغل اليومي مثلا عبارة عن مثلا الجزر فاهمينها في حاجة مش فاهمينها في ال بيزنس كنت بخش مثلا أخد منه
Learner B1: عمل يور ديني أو فارس
Learner B1: وبعد كده منخش على منشوف غبار الديزاين مثلا في حاجة إمم مش زيكوردر يعني كنت بعملها.
Learner B6: يعني أنت كنت حالة الوصل ما بين كلاينت أو السيكلدر والدفتين.
Learner B1: بالظبط ده بعامل البروتوكس ك ماسك من أوله لغاية لما هيشوف إيه موجودة فيه بعد كده الموجودة دلوقتي
Learner B1: بس يعني هو في في شركات بتشغل بروتوكول عادي وفي شركات مثلا شركة زي مثلا
Learner B1: زي نون بيكون يعني خلاص انت يعني كل بتاعك حيكون نون بس
Learner B1: أما سوفتوير إنت ممكن يجيلك كدا كذا بروجيك يعني مثلا مش مش بس لا ممكن يكون حاجات مختلفة.
Learner B6: ، فاهمك انت قصدك مثلا شركة نون شغالة الهاوس برودكتها إنما شركات ثانية انت بتشوف برودكت بتاعة.
Learner B1: بالزبط هي بتكون يعني حد مثلا بيكون محتاج مثلا
Learner B1: فده برودكت من ضمن الحاجات مثلا وغيره بقى.
Learner B6: حلو أوي أصلا. بس أنا يعني لما دخلت وطبعا لسه خريج مقدم جديد كده
Learner B6: لقيت جزء برودكت محتاجين خبرة اقل حاجة تلات سنين، فأنا مستغرب لإيه الرقم ده.
Learner B1: محتاجين إيه معلش.
Learner B6: محتاجين منهم يعني إكسبيرنس 3 سنين على.
Learner B1: في شركات بتطلب كده و فرنش
Learner B1: مثلا بيكونوا حابين بيطلبوا مثلا بتاعتهم أوقات بيكون في كده يعني هو مش
Learner B1: ما عندهمش أو يكون شغال أو ما عايزين حد نكون أوير بالبزنيس بتاعهم فيخش يشتغل على طول.
Learner B6: أم فهمت حلو.
Learner B1: بس بكون في برضه شركات بتوفر عادي يعني.
Learner B6: فاهمك فاهم مظبوط.
Learner B1: خفيف خفيف.
Learner B6: إن شاء الله.
Learner B4: أنا ببعت إيميل. وبعته على بس نو.
Learner B6: تقريبا شايفين إن تيم بتاعنا قليل مش من درجة تقريبا يعني.
Guest B1: هو مش المفروض تقريبا يختاروا ما بين أو حاجة زي كده عشان يبرعني ال
Guest B1: الموضوع أو مثلا هو المفروض يوزع علينا التوسكات.
Learner B6: كانوا في لازم معنا طبقي كده بالضبط هو نفس نفس.
Learner B4: مظبوط واجد.
Learner B4: في حد موجود معانا من عندهم عشان يشرف على الموضوع، لكن هم كده.
Learner B6: شوي.
Learner B1: عيني يابا وأنا بس مش فاهم التوبيك اللي المفروض مثلا نمشي إزاي يعني هم قسموا الجروبز وخلاص.
Learner B6: البوردي المفروضة.
Learner B4: يعني حد زي أوركسترا كده بيشوف إحنا.
Learner B1: يروح يكون في تيست أو طويل أوي.
Learner B4: والتي.
Learner B6: على.
Learner B4: مع.
Learner B6: ده حقيقي. شكرا على السؤال ده يعني.
Learner B1: تمر رهيب.
Learner B6: وحش قوي كان وحش قوي.
Learner B1: كان رهيب. أنا ما فيش طويل يعني هو كل ده كان طويل أوي كان طويل أوي في أسئلة.
Learner B6: كنت عاوز شفتو يعني.
Learner B1: أم.
Guest B1: إيه.
Learner B6: إلى.
Guest B1: هو ما كنش برودكت مانديمنت بس هو كان بيسأل في حاجات في كود في حاجات.
Learner B1: من.
Guest B1: كذا حدا.
Learner B1: إمم.
Learner B6: هو بحط كمان كان في كثير لمواقف يعني محتاجة إكسبيرينس عامة مش محتاجة حد لسا بيتعلم تاني شبه.
Learner B1: و الفيديو التانيين كان لي كان كان تقريبا فيها حاجة ليها علاقة بالفيديو. ما لحقتش أقرأه. عملت سكيب يعني ما لحقتش أقرأها
Learner B1: ماهوش فيها أي حاجة.
Learner B6: بصراحة ما حظيتش كله خالص يعني.
Learner B4: ومحبش الورود. زي ما اها.
Learner B1: ما فيش اهتمام.
Mentor B: السلام عليكم إذا كان.
Learner B6: أستاذ عبد.
Learner B1: غثيان عبور.
Mentor B: تمام الحمد لله معلش حصل بس لخبطة كده تأخرنا عليكم وكان كان معاكم
Mentor B: والمنتور يعني ده حصل تغيير وكده حيتغير فغالبا خليك معايا ثانية وحدة.
Learner B4: فيش أي حد رد فلو جت ونص حنعمل إيه.
Mentor B: أنا معاكو وأنا معك عاملين إيه أولا.
Learner B4: بسم الله الرحمن.
Learner B6: في.
Mentor B: تمام الحمد لله أنا أحمد يوسف معرفتش قابلتوني كنتوا حاضرين في في ولا
Mentor B: أنا وإي آي برودكت أونر أوكس سبرينس
Mentor B: يعني شغال في التك من 2,000 وسبعتاشر اشتغلت في شركات كتير أولهم كانت يداستي لو منكوا حد عارفها
Mentor B: قعدت فيها 4 سنين ونص عملت حاجة كتيرة هناك
Mentor B: وبعد كده اشتغلت في كذا ستارتأب يعني صغيرين شوية كان منهم الكوتش ده فيتنيس ترينج موبايل أب أو يعني وبعد كده زي تالنت وورك بليس كده في السعودية
Mentor B: واشتغلت في شركة دي بتعمل تالنت أوف شورينج للشركات في أوروبا سويسرا. بالأخص يعني هنا وبيشتغلوا بقى للشركات هناك
Mentor B: وفي نفس الوقت يعني. تالنس وكده بتطلع تالنس يعني تشتغل في الترنينغ
Mentor B: وفي سبرينس بقى من 2,000 من يعني سنة ونص كده في سبرنس
Mentor B: يعني سعيد جدا إني أنا معاكوا النهارده انتنشال كتجربة هي حاجة مختلفة وحاجة جديدة إحنا بنبنيها مع بعض
Mentor B: وانتو جزء منها لأن يعني إنتو بتاخدوا إكسبيرينس وفي نفس الوقت إنتو بتفيدونا والبيت بتاعكو هو اللي بنبني على أساسه التجربة دي
Mentor B: ودي تجربة إن شاء الله ممكن يعني كبير جدا على حياة ناس كتير حتت اللي ما بين التعليم وما بين الشغل
Mentor B: جاب يعني ناس كتير بتعاني منها وتبقى خصوصا دلوقتي المجال يعني و فرص الشغل
Mentor B: بيحصل فيه قوي يعني الجو ماركت عامة بيحصل في تغير كبير
Mentor B: وحيبقى البار أعلى في اللي هو عايزين حد يعرف هيجي يعرف يعمل حاجة أو عمل حاجة قبل كده
Mentor B: لأن حتى الواحد يتعلم أو الواحد يعمل حاجة بقت أسهل بسبب هيبقى أعلى
Mentor B: يعني كملت كلمت كتير بس مبسوط هنا ومعانا كمان دلوقتي داخل معانا أحمد مرزوق سينيور برودكت مانجر معانا في ال تيم زميلي وهو اللي كان يعني مسؤول عن بروجكت على بروجكت اللي إنتو بتشتغلوا عليه إن شاء الله
Mentor B: خلونا طيب يعني ممكن نعمل كده انت برودكشن تعارف سريعة لو ممكن كل حد يقول يعني إسمو
Mentor B: جامعته أو أو هو بيشتغل يعني اللي هو بيعمله دلوقتي سواء بيدرس أو بيشتغل أو مثلا خريج ويعني عرفنا عنه كدا اللي هو حابب يقوله يعني.
Learner B4: ماشي ممكن تفيدنا مبدئيا. شكرا باش مهندس على المقدمه واهلا بك يا باش مهندس. احمد
Learner B4: أنا ندى ندى كيرو أنا خريجة 2,000 وتسعتاشر بالاسكندرية
Learner B4: تجارة انزف و بشتغل شغلي كله ملي كان في السوفت وير يعني شوية على ستريس شوية واحيانا بشتغل
Learner B4: يعني جزء برودكت مانجمنت إز جزء منه في من ضمن شغلي. اللي أنا بتعامله مع برودكت أونورز و ديب أوبس فحابة إن أنا آخد تيكنيكال أبسط.
Mentor B: انشغلك شفت وير.
Mentor B: أوكي.
Learner B4: ما.
Mentor B: الشركة اللي شغالة فيها في الإمارات شركة سوفتوير.
Learner B4: سوفت وير أل سوفتوير.
Mentor B: أوكي سيس برودكت يعني.
Learner B4: وقبليها. كنت وقبلها كنت لوشن أجور وام ثري سيكس فايف وال سي آر إم. وهكذا.
Mentor B: حلو جدا ما شاء الله.
Learner B4: فرنش.
Mentor B: اهلا بك. اهلا بك بور سعيده طيب مين تفضل ياسر.
Learner B6: اهلا بحضراتكم انا ياسر أنا بشكر طبعا باش مهندس احمد والبش مهندس
Learner B6: مش موسى احمد دلوقتي انا ياسر أنا خريج حسبات ومعلومات 26 سنة دي بتقديري امتياز في مشروع التخرج أنا مهتم بال برودكت مانجمنت الحمد لله من من سنة ثالثة
Learner B6: كنت بالنسبة كنت موجود فيه دي الوقت دي اتش بروجرام تبع وكنت موجود في هارفرد
Learner B6: يعني وكنت في تي آي تي اي سي بيزنس تريني وزيدني و برودكت أونر و بي تو بي سيز
Learner B6: كنت برضو موجود في هواوي واخدت كذا برودكت مانجمنت و مهتم جدا. ان انا ابتدي شغلي كأس برودكت مانشستر.
Mentor B: تشرفنا بيك فرصة سعيدة ياسر يعني ما شاء الله يعني ناس خبرات عظيمة.
Learner B6: بس.
Mentor B: سعيدة ياسر سعيدة ندى.
Mentor B: لا، لا تفضل بعكس، أنا.
Mentor B: كنت هسألكم شباب برضه إنتو سيلف كده ممكن تقولوا انتو ليه إنتو ل 6 في مانجمنت أوكي
Mentor B: ولو ممكن الناس اللي قالت تقول بردو معاها يعني.
Learner B4: إيه ماشي أنا شركتي كانت شغالة في الإمارات بس
Learner B4: وحاليا عملنا في السعودية وأنا تاني فأنا بشتغل كلوز لي جدا معبس يعني حتى فيتشرز اللي بتطلع أنا بعملها تيستينج وبرجع بفيد
Learner B4: بس بتاعتي بيزنس وايتز
Learner B4: مش بقدر إن أنا أدي أدفايس أو إن أنا أقدر أكون في بتاعة سبرينس بشكل فعال من ناحية تيكنيكال السهل إي فاليبريدس بتاعته معقدة ووركراوند ومش بقدر أعمل كده
Learner B4: محتاجة أكون فاهمة اكتر ومي دي ون زي إننا آموت برودكت نو.
Mentor B: مش عظيم ماشي يا سيف.
Learner B6: تمام أنا كنت في الكلية لما كنت بتكلم مع صحابي اكثر في البروجكتس وهكذا كانوا بيتكلموا عن الجراز معين او الاحسن، وهذا يوفر علينا وقت ازاي وهكذا
Learner B6: يعني أنا كنت بكلمهم عن ناحية البزنس وده حيفيدنا ازاي كفاليو وهكذا وال يوزر حيستخدمه ازاي
Learner B6: بعدين ولو ممكن نعمل برضو نسأل المستخدمين الحاجة اللي هتفيدهم او هكذا يعني أنا الحمد لله كنت تيم ليدر في كذا بروجكت وكنت واصل بريزن في في الجامعة فحبيت اكتر حتة ليدر شيب مانجمنت وهكذا
Learner B6: وكنت حابب أربط ما بين التكنكل والبزنس فقعدت أدور وأبحث عن موضوع أكتر لقيت إن هو برودك مانجمنت ده أكثر حاجة مناسبة لي.
Mentor B: مين بعد ياسر.
Learner B1: مقننة.
Mentor B: ماشي تفضلي.
Learner B1: الغبور يربكم خير أنا اسمي. عادل هنري، أنا متخرج من 20
Learner B1: اشتغلت فترة عملت اشتغلت فترة أومر
Learner B1: في شركة تطوير كانت إي وورك سبتها ورحت شركة كبريت واشتغلت فيها فوق التهم
Learner B1: بس دلوقتي قلت يعني عايز أجدد تفكيري وأشوف بروجكت فقلت خود الانترنت.
Mentor B: ان شاء الله تبقى عظيمة دي كعادل وتبقى كلها تعلم ان شاء الله.
Learner B1: إن شاء الله.
Mentor B: ان شاء الله حلو ماشي كده ياسر وندى قالوا وعادل مين بعد عادل.
Learner B5: ممكن أنا.
Mentor B: ماشي تفضلي يا.
Learner B5: أنا روان علي خريجة جوائز السنة دي ولسه بكتشف الحياة. هو
Learner B5: أنا مهتمة بالمجال ده بصراحة علشان ده حلقة الوصل بين البزنس والتكنولوجيا.
Learner B5: حابة أعرفه أكتر وكمان كنت شغالة في ال في الكلية على مشروع
Learner B5: الجزر اكتشفت. إني مش حابة أكتب كود بس أو أبني فيتشرز وخلاص أنا حابة. إني أحل مشكلة حقيقية. بتواجه الناس
Learner B5: ويسهل عليهم شوي بس.
Mentor B: جيمت جيمت حلوة أوي ماشي شكرا شهد.
Guest B1: أنا اشتغلت سيد تخرجت من السنة اللي فاتت دخلت أكتيڤيتيز فيها بروجكت ويك آي إكس ديزاين
Guest B1: ودخلت مصر رواد مصر الرقمية في اليو اي اكس ديزاين
Guest B1: ودخلت أنت في المجال واشتغلت في الشركة فول تايم هي سوفت وير هاوس
Guest B1: في الحقيقة محبة المجال لأن أنا حسيت على مدار الفترة اللي أنا كنت شغالة فيها يو اي اكس
Guest B1: كنت بشتغل على انترنت برودكتس للشركة
Guest B1: فأنا كنت بعمل آيديشن للبيزنس كنت بعمل ماركت ديسير كنت بفكر في جريكس
Guest B1: وفي كذا مجال يعني، فحسيت إن ال برودكت يعني هيكون باين
Guest B1: دي كلها وكمان هيبقى في أوفر فيو مش بس يو إكس في ديبارتمنتس التانية وأنا حابة إن أنا أجينز بتاعت
Guest B1: بتاعت المجاني يعني مأنا حابة المانجمل بصراحة
Guest B1: إيه بس إن شاء الله تكون لذيذة يعني مبسوطة إن أنا ما هو يعني بس.
Mentor B: شكرا.
Guest B1: إمم.
Mentor B: لا إحنا كده خلصنا كلنا صح ولا محمد محمد حاتم.
Mentor B: لا حاتم بس يعني كان ميتينغ تمام.
Mentor B: حاتم تبعنا. أوكي أنا كنت شاكك شباب أنا أحمد مرزوق انا ببانيتش يعني في منهم تي
Mentor B: أنا أديكو هيتب برضه عن سبونس كده عشان تخيلوا الدنيا عندنا انترنالي
Mentor B: نبدأ برضه هي نتكلم على شغال عليها برضه عشان إيه حتبدوا من هذا السكوب تبدؤوا تشوفوا اللي انتو هتمسكوها وتحلوها في
Mentor B: أوكي حلو أنا بس أدوني جاست ون منوت هالشي كريم لحظة واحدة بس
Mentor B: شباب انت مين صح.
Learner B6: تمام يا فندم.
Mentor B: ماشي يلا خلينا نبتدي استنى بس
Mentor B: ماشي لو إنتو شايفين هنا إحنا في سبرنس شغالين على كذا
Mentor B: في الأسسمنت يعني عشان نقيم في نفس الوقت عندنا في اللي هو تي آي تي دا عبارة عن برودكت إنت بتدخله بتدخله كونتنت وفكرة عايز تعمل كوس عليه ويطلعلك الناحية التانية بتاعك وواضح كأنك عامل
Mentor B: قوسين كل ده سو باي لاين يو آي بي لاين يعني عندنا تالنس هو موديل كدا اسمه يو أوف
Mentor B: عشان الشيكات عشان المصريين في مصر
Mentor B: فجت فكرة إن هو يبقى سيروبالتي
Mentor B: هو اللي مهاير دول التانس دول شغالين لحد ده موقفهم القانوني يعني إيه معوق يعني طبعا في ديلو ويموت بس ويموت لو عندكم معلومات عنهم ودي عاملين نفس الموديل
Mentor B: وعندنا طبعا هي بين الجدودس وبين سوق العمل.
Mentor B: فطبعا. إنتو تيجي تقدموا علي شغل إحنا محتاجين إكسبريس تكون اشتغلت طب ومن هنا جت فكرة طب إحنا ما نعمل كومبني الناس تشتغل فيها اللي هي سبينس دلوقتي يعني الناس تشتغل فيها وتبدأ إيه تأخذ دي بنفسها يعني
Mentor B: متفقين حلو لحد هنا حد عنده أي سؤال
Mentor B: أوكي إفتحوا المايكات كده وادفعلوا عادي ماشي اللي انتو عليه دلوقتي وبوبلوم وحتعيشوا بتاعة مانج مانجمنت على هذا فدي ميلي أنا بسرعة كده الستاكل اللي عندنا طبعا
Mentor B: ويمكن الأخير اللي هو آي لينك كومبانيون وده كومبانيون بساعدك كدا إيه إن هو يجاوب على أسئلتك وتبقى اللينج اللونينغ جيرنيد أي حاجة محتاجها هو يبدأ يساعدك ويقولك فهمك أكتر هذه الاشياء
Mentor B: وطبعا هو بيكون عافك أكتر طب إحنا شرحنا طبعا عندنا الأساسي بتاعنا وهو عبارة عن
Mentor B: زي أي مقاس عادي بتنزل عليه بتاعتكوا بتبدأوا تتعلموا عليه زيو زي كوسيوا أو زي يودي ميعادي
Mentor B: فده كدا مني كل اللي عندنا ملي في خليني أقول حاجة إن هي ده بيجمع ديتابوينز عن
Mentor B: بتاعتهم وطريقة تفاعلهم و التاسكات اللي بسلموها عشان في الآخر يبني بروفايل لكل منا والبوفايل ده طبعا بنستفاد منه في النهاية في التقييم وفي لو في حيصل انترنالي أو حيحصل طبعا برضه البوفايلز دي بتشتغل مع هيومتوز عشان هاي موتوز
Mentor B: كراينز
Mentor B: فهي دي الفكرة الفكرة العامة من منشنت فأنتو إنتو هتعلموا إيه هنا إنتو حتاخدوا إزاي يعني أنا كل اللي بكلمهم دول دلوقتي قدامي
Mentor B: عندهم جميع اللي هم يشتغلوا بيها كبودة مانشست
Mentor B: حلو إنت متوقع إن إنت يعني أنا متوقع إن إنت قادر إن إنت تعمل هذا الطاسك وفي نفس الوقت، بتاعتك هي أول بوتس أنا بستفيد منها يعني تخيل مثلا وأنت شغال وماسك برودكت معين
Mentor B: فطبعا ده محتاج طبعا شغل كتير ومحتاج ديديكاشن ومحتاج لأنه هو مانجمنت برضه مختلفة شوية بطبيعتها لإن هي فأنت مفروض تبقى أكثر حد فاهم عن المشكلة اللي إنت ماسكها أو اللي ماسكه انت الشخص اللي إحنا بنروح له لما نكون مزنوقين ونقوله طب احنا هنا نعمل إيه
Mentor B: فطبعا ده محتاج إن أنت قوي كل بودر
Mentor B: عشان نبدأ نستفاد من ده وفي نفس الوقت ما فيش حد لا إنت صح وغلط ده هو الموقف اللي بيقولك إنت صح وغلط فأنت ما تنتظرش إن هي دي تبقى ستايل لا، إنت عملت دي صح؟ إنت عملت دي غلط أمال الضو هنا هيبقى أو المنتو اللي هيكون معاكو
Mentor B: هو دون هو يديك اللي انت محتاجها هو كحد اشتغل بودك مانجر فهو عايز يديك المين سيت بتاعة اللي انت تقدر تجوب بيها في أي حاجة أو تقدر تحل بيها أي مشكلة
Mentor B: لأن دي بالضبط ال ماتيريالز الموجودة في كل مكان يعني إنت مش عارف حاجة تسأل هيعلمهالك او كلود حتى ينفذهالك، لكن نفسها دي بتتبني إيه بالإكسبيرينس فإحنا هنا بنحاول
Mentor B: ندي بقى الماي سات دي نبني اللى حتكون اللي هتكون حاجات فيك يعني وهي الخبرة اللي بتحتاجها الشركات الأخرى
Mentor B: حلو
Mentor B: خلينا كده الكلام ده إحنا أدينا بيه كله احنا بس عندنا أكتيڤيتيز أكتيڤيتي غريب شوية بس عشان آيس كدا
Mentor B: دلوقتي أنا عارف الحاجات دي ممكن تكون صح وغلط يعني هما الاثنين ممكن لازما يحصلوا بس أنا عايز عشان نعرف بعض أكتر
Mentor B: كل 1 يختار حاجة منهم أجين أنا عارف إن في لازم يكونوا موجودين
Mentor B: بس إيه وما فيش حد غلط لا سيليكت أيتم إنت شايفه بتاعتك إحنا كل حد لأن بعدين أنا حخليكم تحفظوا دي هتفقل لما تيجي تخلص إن شاء الله الأيام تنشد
Mentor B: فايند
Mentor B: أو المناسبة ليك لأن هو جدا الحاجات دي لو حددتها تقدر تحدد إنت عايز تشتغل فين والباشون بتاعك فين في
Mentor B: فالله بينا نبتدي.
Learner B4: اختار ما بين كل أوبشن والتاني. صح؟
Mentor B: تختاري 1
Mentor B: ماشي ماشي تفضل.
Learner B4: أوكي أنا حختار جيب فاوست.
Mentor B: 1,000.
Learner B4: أوي.
Mentor B: أوكي.
Learner B4: انا بالظبط ولا ترنداتر
Learner B4: بص طبيعة شغلي تالك يوزرز بس تعلمت إنه هي يعني أصدق من من تو يوزرز الصراحة أب وإنتو.
Mentor B: أوه، حلوة ماشي بس إنت هتختاري منهم لو هتعملي واحدة هتختاري إيه.
Learner B4: إن أوقات يوزرز هم ما يبقاش فاهمين هم محتاجين فعلا
Learner B4: هو مقتنع هو فاهم بس دي الحقيقة يعني.
Mentor B: ال.
Learner B4: يعني على ام جي بي هادول بيحقق المنيوم ف طبيعي يعني كده كيف.
Mentor B: من.
Learner B4: ما اعرفش.
Mentor B: واتس بوقف انت قلت هنا أوقف واتس بوكن ولا أوبيل ده سومثينج يو عشان ما سمعتش 1 تاني.
Learner B4: أنا ما قلتهاش والله هو حاسه ان هو ادبنت يعني بس خلينا بيل سومثينج يو.
Mentor B: أوكي طب إنتي قلتي عامل في بتاعتك مش شرط تكون عامل يعني عادي جدا إن أنا دلوقتي بي بس أنا لو أخفيكم سواء بحب البوتو سي أكتر يعني.
Learner B4: مش عارفة اللي حاصل عشان يعني تشتغل على ماسبس يعني سيمبل ومحتاج انك تعمل منو انت الموضوع بيبقى واسع شوية مش ملموم على قد ال توبي.
Mentor B: ماشي حلو قوي ماشي شكرا ياسر تفضلي. آسف.
Learner B6: أنا بالنسبة لي أول نقط أول فيتشر إن إحنا نشيل فاست أند فيكس ليتر لأن ده كان مارك تكلم عنها قبل كده إن إحنا في فيسبوك كذا فيتشر وبعد كده لو في أي مشاكل بنعدل عليها بعدين
Learner B6: وبعد كده غير الموضوع ده اللي انت ما تغيرش، فأهم حاجة عندنا في بروتوكس مانشمنت. إن أنا.
Mentor B: أنا بقولك على حاجة هنا. أقولك حاجة هنا فخ في بوتكس ما تنفعش غير تشيب بوينس
Mentor B: نفس يعني في بعض المديولز نفس الفكرة يعني قصدي في حاجات يعني هنا برضه ما فيش صحة أو غلط في بعض بوينتس لأن هو على حسب طبيعة إنت بتحب أنهي شكل من الأشكال دي فاهم قصدي.
Learner B6: تمام أنا كياسر بحب إن أنا أجيب تومات بأسرع شكل ممكن.
Mentor B: حلو ماشي حلو.
Learner B6: ثاني نقطة بالنسبة لليوزر. أو أنا بصراحة، أنا بحب داتا أكثر ليه بكون عندي أقدر أتكلم مع مثلا بتكلم عليه ده متوسط بديته معينة.
Learner B6: طبعا اللوزرز مهمين لانهم هم كده بيستخدموا فيتشر بس احيانا اليوزر بيقول مثلا حل ما بيقولش المشكلة نفسها لازم تقعد
Learner B6: مشكله فهذه ممكن يديك حل فالحل هذا ليس مناسب ليزر ثاني فتبقى لفة قليلا الفيتشر الفيتشرز. بالنسبة لي انا
Learner B6: يعني أنا أنزل السوق بسرعة يبقى ثري فيتشر دن ويل إنوف ده بالنسبة لي احسن ان انا ما فيش حتة برودكتس أكيد لازم كدا كدا لازم ويبقى في شغالين أجرايل وهكذا
Learner B6: الشخص بتعرف.
Mentor B: بتاع.
Learner B6: جدا.
Mentor B: الله يسلمك.
Learner B6: بعد كده الاثنين محترمة بينهم على حسب الفيتشر نفسها هل هي ستاند لون لوحدها ممكن حاجة تانية؟ أو لا الفيتشر دي معتمدة على حاجة تانية لازم الفكس الأول بعد كده يعني مثلا ما ينفعش مثلا في طلبات
Learner B6: فيتشر بتاعة البيمنتس تكون مش شغالاه كويس أو الفيتشر ما ينفعش أنزل بدون ما تكون الفتشر دي كويسة.
Learner B6: ففي الحالة دي انا لازم افكسي البروبليم دي قبل ما انزل فيتش الجديدة مثلا. زي الطلبات وهكذا.
Mentor B: الوقت يد
Mentor B: أوكي ماشي عادل فكوله خير يلا عادي.
Learner B1: كان مثلا كفكرة ممكن بس مش مور قوي يعني يعني
Learner B1: يعني عشان البنت ما يتغيرش أو ماركت ما يتغيرش قوي.
Mentor B: جيمز هاف.
Learner B1: إمم
Learner B1: رأي الجزار مهم وكلامه مهم بس يا سلام لو في داتا بقى يعني هو داتا أساسي بس يعني.
Mentor B: في.
Learner B1: عرفوا مشاكله من كلامه هو يعني برضه الندى مش هي اللي بتتعمل أكثر حاجة بس يعني رأي مهم برضه.
Mentor B: طب إنتو عارفين إيه السؤال ده
Mentor B: في المراحل الأولية لل برودكتس محتاج أكتر. تتكلم مع يوزرز في المراحل بتاعة بتاعة وتشوف بيفورز وبعد كده بس هي ده الأهم وبعد كده؟ تروح تتكلم مع اليوزر فاهمين قصدي فعشان تعرفوا بس كل 1 بتاعكو بتوديه فين يعني 1 حيحب قوي يشتغل
Mentor B: على المراحل الأولانية بتاعة ال ام في مثلا والمراحل بتاعت لكن 1 ثاني آخر. حيحب أنا عايزك ماتيو مثلا زي طلبات مثلا وأنا
Mentor B: كم يعدولك.
Learner B1: أنا ولا يهمك مش مشكلة.
Mentor B: أم.
Learner B1: يعني ما أفضلش أحطه خلاص.
Mentor B: الو.
Learner B1: لا ممكن الأول أشوف على حسب إي يعني على حسب يعني هي المشكلة هو اللي معطلني لو حاجة بسيطة قابلت حاجة جديدة ماشي
Learner B1: أما لو الفكس دي مثلا لو البروك دي حاجة مهمة لأ يبقى الجديد اللي ممكن يتبني.
Mentor B: ماشي.
Learner B1: يعني هو برضو على حسب إي المهم مش شايفة عيني.
Mentor B: مش شايفة.
Learner B1: عيب يعني مش فرق.
Mentor B: يعني انت حابب الاتنين.
Mentor B: ده مثالي عادي.
Learner B1: أفق.
Mentor B: هاي شركة تتمناك أوكي مين بعد عادة
Mentor B: نحن ندى وياسر وعادل يا الله بنا ياو لاحد دخل.
Learner B5: تمام حاضر أول حاجة هي بتعتمد على مرحلة المنتج لو المنتج. الجديد إم بي الأفضل هتبقى شيب فوست عشان.
Mentor B: ما فيش ما فيش صح وغلط يعني ما فيش هي بتعتمد على مرحلة المنتجات بتاعتك إنتي بتحبي تشتغلي كده ولا كده بس ما فيش صحة وغلط.
Learner B5: والله.
Mentor B: مثالية أكثر من عادل. آسف، طيب.
Learner B5: بس هو الريزيش مر حساها تبقى أحسن شوية يعني.
Mentor B: أم.
Learner B5: أجمع ده وكده.
Mentor B: حلو كويس.
Learner B5: بعد كده التكت يوزر ولا ده التنين بيكملوا بعض يعني داتا بتقول لنا اللي بيحصل وال يوزر بيقولنا اللي بيحصل انا بستخدم.
Mentor B: طيب.
Learner B5: على نعم.
Mentor B: ديار.
Learner B5: أنا رديت.
Mentor B: ماشي.
Learner B5: اللي بعد كده حختار أرفري فيتشرز.
Learner B5: وبعد كده هختار الفكس أكيد.
Mentor B: أوكي أفيكس الحال، ماشي.
Mentor B: أنا بحبش أشيل يعني الصناعية بحبش أشيل شغلي بس مش كملتي.
Learner B5: بالضبط.
Mentor B: أنت مثالية وعمرك.
Learner B5: بعد كده أختار والله التنين حلوين بحبش أختار بينهم يعني دول بالذات
Learner B5: حلوين أنا مع أي حد فيهم.
Mentor B: ماشي عظيم كده فاضل شحت.
Guest B1: في أنا حختار ان انا اعمل
Guest B1: لأن ده ال أبوتشر لأنا دايما باخده بحب أنفس وقت في ال أكتر لأنه هو اللي بيطلعلي مثلا
Guest B1: اللي ممكن حد غير يعملها في برودكت بتاعو فبقى أنا رايس ده تاديه يبقى
Guest B1: أحسن ما شوب فاستر يعني وتطلعليكس كتير أقعد هضيع وقتي في إن أنا أصرحها بالنسبالي برضه
Guest B1: بصراحة أنا يعني بعمل التنين بس أنا بحب أتوج تو يوزرز أكتر يعني لو مثلا ناس حولي أو إن أنا أكادر إنفورميشنز من أو كده يعني بتكون لايف داتا
Guest B1: في ال دي ستاج بالذات بشوف الناس مثلا وجهة نظرها بتبقى إزاي أو فكرتها عن برودكت ده
Guest B1: يعني أفضل إن أنا برضه أعمل ون فيتشر
Guest B1: أحسن من تلاتة فيتشرز يعني هيبقى فوكس أونت مور وهيطلع رزاز أحسن
Guest B1: وهفيكس واتش بروكن برضه لأن مقدرش إننا أبلدي بروكن يعني كله في الآخر أيوا عليا
Guest B1: وهختار في الآخر بي تو بي هو أوت أوف إكسبيرينس بصراحة يعني ما اسمك.
Mentor B: شكرا.
Guest B1: في.
Mentor B: صعبة ما بين حاجتين صح لأن هم الاتنين لازم يحصلوا بس هو إيه أنا كنت حابب ابخم في يعني أصعب ال أكتيڤيتي؟ يعني
Mentor B: أوكي ماشي نعم، أنا ما قلتش رأيي أنت عايز تعرف رأيي.
Learner B1: المهم.
Mentor B: أوكي يلا كويس أنا شيف شيف فاست إنفكس ليتر والله يعني يعني وأنا بتتغير مع السن يعني
Mentor B: أنا كنت زمان بحب أشيف فاست لكن دلوقتي أحب شوية بس ستيل تبع شيف باستير
Mentor B: يعني يعني واقف ما بينهم كده شفت بقى التضليل واقف فين أنا واقف في النص يعني كده توك يوز داتا لا، طبعا أنا بحب داتا بحب داتا أكثر بكثير يعني بحب البوتوكس اللي فيها ديتا بحب أنا رايس فيها
Mentor B: نص كوم لأن نص كوم نيو
Mentor B: يعني أنا أكثر إبني زيوت يعني الديني في وأنت بتبتدي كده تمام أنا معاك يعني
Mentor B: بي تو سي أو بي تو بي لا أنا بي تو سي أكثر بكثير يعني
Mentor B: بس ده بالنسبة لي.
Learner B4: أنا لسا كنت هقول يو أر ماي في الشغل حق مولتي في تو سي بس أوكي.
Mentor B: صح.
Learner B4: في.
Mentor B: أوكي ماشي خلينا بقى نتكلم عن البزنس بتاعتنا بس قبل ما تمشي إزاي
Mentor B: أولا ويلكم يعني بتوعنا انتوا عندكم مشكلة خطيرة خطيرة جدا في سبرينس
Mentor B: وهي مشكله بتقول ان احنا دلوقتي الناس
Mentor B: لا هيبص كثير إحنا عايزين نكتشف ليه الناس بتتشن من التعليم عامة، وهي عامة مشكلة يعني لو انتو بصيتوا على كومبليشن ويت
Mentor B: جلوبلي هتلاقي في عامة كومبليشن ويت نص كومب كده إلا يعني مثلا كوانتك وديولينغو اللي حاولوا يحلوا المشكلة بشكل مختلف أعلى من الماوك شوية بسبب الطريقة اللي هم بيعلموا بها الناس
Mentor B: فانت دلوقتي الصينيت إحنا عندنا فيديو جدا جدا يعني زي شبه هي كروسيا بالضبط تخش تحضر تسلم السايمنت يبقى عندك طسك معرفش إيه فإحنا دلوقتي عايزين
Mentor B: نطور من هذه لينينج إكسبيرينس
Mentor B: عشان تحسن عشان نحسن ممكن تقولي في مشكلة هنا مش شرط تكون دي دي المشكلة إن هي أنا معاك تماما لو مش هي دي المشكلة قشطة يعني كده إنت بدأت تفكر
Mentor B: حد يجيلك انت محتاج توقف في ويك وان وهو عندي مشكلة في
Mentor B: فأنا عايز أحسن أحسن النقطة دي فإنت محتاج بقى كويس جدا وهي المرحلة الأخطر التي يكون فيها كل حاجة يعني إحنا بنبل فوقيها فهي المرحلة
Mentor B: فيها ممكن تحدد شمال غرب جنوب فأنت ممكن يوديك أصلا عكس الاتجاه، فأنت المرحلة دي محتاج تكون ديجيت فيها جدا.
Mentor B: محتاج جدا طبعا أنا بحطولكم تشيك بوينتس وأنا عشان تساعدكم تفهموا زي مثلا
Mentor B: تبني بسونا تعمل يوزوم تعمل ديز مثلا ولكن كل دوت بيصب
Mentor B: في حاجة وهي الحاجة التي يعيش فيها وهي اللي تفصل عن عن بيت الناس اللي بتفكر في الشركة
Mentor B: حد يعرفها إيه هي من قبل ما نكمل كده حد يعني يعرف إيه المختلف في طريقة صعب جدا أنا عارف بس إيه اللي مختلف في طريقة برودك يعني برودك مانجر بتاعته مختلف عن بقية الشركة
Mentor B: التفكير حد عندو أي جسكنة قولي يا.
Learner B4: أنا أقول لا أنا ما عنديش يعني في الحتة دي بس ممكن إن هو طول الوقت لو قلت مثلا الحل ده هو الحل الأمثل فلي ده الحل الأمثل ليه ما يكونش الحاجة طول الوقت يبقى في ديسكوفري كويستيان لحد ما نوصل بتاع كل شيء.
Mentor B: قريبة بس مش هي دي قريبة بس وناس.
Learner B6: ممكن تكون اللي هو شايف مثلا البروج ده حيمشي كويس أو حيعمل فاليه معين.
Mentor B: البودكس سينس لا.
Learner B6: يعني مثلا مختلفة عن اللي هو عايز أطلع أحسن حاجة
Learner B6: أحسن فيتشر أو أحسن معين عشان يوفرلي برودكت مانجر يبص لناحية ال يوزر أو يبص ناحية الفاليو أكتر
Learner B6: فده اللي بيفرغه بقى عن باقي تيم مثلا تيم السيلز عايز يبيع وخلاص تيم ماركتينغ عايز يروج سينس أو هو ده أهم حاجة.
Mentor B: وايد بس مش.
Learner B4: طيب ممكن يكون البورترازيشن.
Mentor B: لأ فرنش.
Learner B1: ممكن يكون.
Mentor B: ما يدروا.
Learner B1: قول ولا.
Mentor B: قولوا.
Learner B1: ممكن يكون إن مثلا بيفكر كتفكير استراتيجي شوية اللي هو ده حيكون قدام عامل إزاي أما مثلا كل والناس اللي معاه بيفكروا في اللحظة دي.
Mentor B: السيوس بتفكر ميرسي ليفيل يعني أكثر منك أصلا مشاية
Mentor B: أقول لوكو طيب ماشي حد عايز يحول ثاني
Mentor B: أوكي ماشي
Mentor B: وهي هذه النقطة الفاصلة يعني لو قراءته في الكتب هي النقطة الفاصلة اللي بتخلي وهو السر إيه إن إنت بتفكر في ال سبيس أكثر من سبيس
Mentor B: يعني إنت بتفكر في حب مش في حب يعني ده حيوديك في في هتبقى في كارثة كده لأن إنت إيه بتدافع عن يعني مايت إن هو إيه مش شغال لكن بقى لو إنت
Mentor B: بتدوز بقى للمشكلة صح وعايز أنت إيه المشكلة اللي بتحلها
Mentor B: ساعتها إنت تقدر تجيب أي لأن إنت كل الشركة كل يوم الصبح يقولك ما تيجي نعمل فيشر الفلانية طب إيه رأيك لو عملنالها بالحاجة الواحد تنين تلاتة لو كده لكن إنت أي حد يقولك حتى بما فيهم سي أو محتاج إحنا محتاجين نعمل 1 اتنين تلاتة لازم ترجع غير كده وتقول إحنا إيه إحنا بنحل إيه أصلا
Mentor B: اللي بنحله المشكلة الأول
Mentor B: عشان هي دي نقطة الانطلاق بتاعنا اللي تحدد إحنا مش اتجاه صح أو اتجاه غلط طبعا الموضوع يقع في كثيرة يعني مانجر يونيك بس دي النقطة لجميع يعني معظم اللي أنا اتفقوا عليها
Mentor B: فا
Mentor B: فعشان كده إنت لازما من من هنا ورايح أي في حد يقولك فيتش تقول طب وات إف بقى تسيبك انت من أي حد بقى بتفكروشن لا تفكر زمان لو تفتكوا المايست بتاعتي أنا شخصيا بتاعتي قبل ما أدخل البوتكس
Mentor B: أو مثلا ما يعملوش الفيتش الفلانية 1 2 3 الفولانية دي لأ هو مش مش شرط إنه يكون البزنس محتاجها يعني في
Mentor B: تقريبا ما عرفتوش يعني أنا كنت اشتغلت في سبيستون واشتغلت قبل كده وإشتغلت في سبونس الكبيرة قابلت قابلت هذا إن هو لا يمكن تبقى فانكي واو وما أعرفش إيه بس هل هل ده أصلا هو بيزنس بتاعنا
Mentor B: هل دوت؟ هو اللي هيحل المشاكل اللي هي بتخلي يوزر مش قادر يكمل الجبت بتاعته اللي جاي يعمله
Mentor B: لأن أنا ممكن أروح أركز في فيتشر مثلا إني
Mentor B: يعني خليني أعملك اعملك مثال يعني مثلا ماكدونالز ممكن تروح أنا أقولك أنا هبني مع إن أصلا مشكلة ماكدونالز في كواليتي الأكل. طب ما أنت قبل ما تبني الدواي السودا
Mentor B: تركز مشكلة الأكل لأن دي أصلا حاجة ريسكي بتهدد مبيعاتك فأنت لو فاهم المشكلة كويس وفاهم أبعادها هتنطلق منها وتبدأ توصل
Mentor B: حلو لكن لو مش فاهمها فأكيد مش حتجيب حلو الكلام ده.
Learner B4: تحفة.
Mentor B: ماشي فاحنا العودة كبوت مانجر
Mentor B: هنخلع عباءة التفكير في ونمسك عبئة التفكير في البول فعشان كده ويك ون هو أهم ويك ليه لأن إحنا بنكتشف فيه هو بتاعه هو البوبلوم اللي بتحلها حلو الكلام فإحنا ده ويك وان
Mentor B: ويكوان بعد ما خلصنا ندخل وهنا الكلام العالي. ما هو اللي طلعت بيها وإنت طلعت بكذا بوبلوم ممكن يعني قصدي إحنا عايزين نحاول بزنس 1
Mentor B: لو حلينا كذا هيحقق زي مثلا يعني معظم الشركات اللي اشتغلت فيها كانت زي تفكر طيب هل ده ممكن يكون مثلا بوبل هتروح تحلها دلوقتي
Mentor B: هي كثيرة بس هي أصلا،
Mentor B: فأنت ممكن تحل 3 و4 5 ثانية قبلها يعملولك أكتر من ريفنز اللي حتحلها فهو بقى إي فكرة الإضواء فكرة البزنس نيدز أصلا عايز يحقق إيه
Mentor B: فهو ده اللي إنتو حتحاولوا تعملوه ويكس ثري إيه خلاص ويك ثري ده برضه ليه لأن إحنا مانجمنت بتتغير جدا معالم ال إي آي
Mentor B: والناس بدأت تبحث عن الوقت إنت عندك تولز زي فايف كودينغ تولز اللي هي لافوفول مثلا كلود كود فيزيو أي حاجة من الحاجات ديت
Mentor B: دي بتبني يعني بتساعدك مش تبني في بساعدك تبني كاملة يعني أحد الأمثلة أنا يعني مهتم بالستوكس
Mentor B: فمثلا امبارح وجدت ويب سايت مبني بيدي قيمة عالية جدا من الستوكس التكنة الستوكسكريبشن ويفني و موديل وكل الكلام ده يوم 1 مطلعه في
Mentor B: خلينا نقول في أسبوع ولا أسبوعين، فهو موضوع جدا يعني فإنت دلوقتي بقيت في بتاعتك
Mentor B: تبني بها كاملة فهو ده المستوى بتاع ال مانجمنت في الوقت الحالي اللي احنا مش عارفين فين مش عارف ممكن يعملوا بشرة بدلنا إحتمال قائم يعني مش قليل بس مش كبير يعني مش مستحيل يعني
Mentor B: فإحنا حنشوف يعني الموضوع سيتطور لفين إنتو لازم تتعلموا ال سكيلدي عشان تطلعوا مانجر
Mentor B: يعني يعني متعلمين وجاهزين للتغيير اللي بيحصل في المكتب
Mentor B: حلو فأنتو ودي تقريبا لافبل طول كده حتشوفوا اللي إحنا وصلناله واللي إحنا عملناه وتبدأوا في نهاية يعني فول فونكشنال سوليوشن حلو
Mentor B: وده الويك بقى اللي هيبقى في الدم وفي الكلام الجامد بتاع الشركة بتوعنا يعني الأربعة عندنا كلهم
Mentor B: بسام وأيمن وكده وأنا فيتاخذ يعني بتاعت التقييم
Mentor B: فأنتو في ويك فو ده هتبقى في جيتي ام بلان أوتومات بلان اللي إنت عملته عشان نتعلم و يعني عشان نتابع لأن هو
Mentor B: أهم ما يأتي في إنت ممكن وكلنا كبشر غلط بس الهم لأن إنت لو توصل دائما للإيه الصح
Mentor B: فأنت لازم في ثاني لا ده متابع
Mentor B: شايف التغيير اللي بيحصل فده الأساس فأنتابع منها
Mentor B: وطبعا وهتعمل وكل الكلام بقى عشان تسلم وهيبقى في بقى بعد ويك فوق إيه مانجمنت عندنا
Mentor B: ده جورني بتاعة سبنت بتاعتنا هي فعلا فأنا متوقع إن إنتو أشخاص
Mentor B: فاهمين عارفين يعني ما بتعرفوش قدامكوا حاجة ودي مانست محتاجين تتعلموها جدا يعني هو أكتر حد قادر يوصل للمعلومة ليه
Mentor B: لأن هو ما فيش حد بيجي يقولو ما فيش حد بيجي يقول له أصل إنت هتعمل إكسا واي زاد أو أو حد بيقول له إنت عملت صح أو غلط لأن المقت هو اللي بيقولك إنت عملت صح أو غلط
Mentor B: ماشي
Mentor B: فهنا النقطة المهمة إن إنت عندك في كل مكان، فأنت أي حاجة هو واقف قدامها الحاجة ديتعمل إزاي إسأل الأم إنت إزاي أصلا أطور نفسي في الحتة دي
Mentor B: دائما اسأل السؤالين دول اعملها إزاي صح اللي ناقص المشكلة فأنت
Mentor B: فأنا متوقع منك إن المعلومة ودي ماين يعني دي سكيل مانجمنت سكيل عظيمة. لو تعلمون، يعني سكيل كثير عن ناس أخرى لأن لو أنت بتعرف تروح تشوف الحاجة وتتعلمها بنفسك
Mentor B: تعلمها بنفسك، ده مع الوقت حيعملك كده حيخليك شخص ثقيل يعني في المعلومات يعني حلو ده برضه دي حاجة تانية أنا بتوقعها منكوا يعني
Mentor B: وأحمد يوسف بتوقعها يعني خلينا ندخل بقى في اللي إحنا حنحلها
Mentor B: ماشي أنا تكلمت الديسكو عن سريعا كدا شايف اللابتوب مش شغال ليه هو انتو شايفين السكرين.
Learner B6: حتى.
Mentor B: ميرسي
Mentor B: انا اساعدكم واعطيكم حبة هيدبز ممكن تكون صح؟ ممكن تكون غلط ما اعرفش الكلام هذا حقيقي. ولا غير حقيقي
Mentor B: فأنتم محتاجين تتشكوا يعني عاملوني كستيك هولدر جاي لكم المشكلة، فما تتبعوش كلامي البحث بتاعكم بس إنتو عايزين في الآخر أوبجيكتيف إن إحنا نقلل وبالتالي نزود ال بيبي
Mentor B: فممكن ما فيش إنجمنت هوبس عندنا تخلي الناس تكمل ما فيش أكاونتابيليتي ليا وإن تخلي الناس تحس إن هي مسؤولة فتكمل ما فيش فيدباك لوب
Mentor B: ما فيش مثلا يعني بوينت تخلي الناس يدخلوا لو هم ممكن طريقة التعلم نفسها تكون طريقة مملة جدا كلها محتاجين تدوروا وتشوفوا الناس
Mentor B: طب الناس اللي حلوا المشكلة دي حلوها ازاي و وانتو لو حتحلوا المشكلة دي حتطلعوها عشان تبقى سبينس إيه يعني حلت المشكلة دي
Mentor B: بس كده.
Mentor B: أقاطعك بس دقيقة دي الوقت إحنا محتاجين نقفل ده لو الميتينج يعني مكملين ممكن وبعتهولكوا مثلا ونخش عليك
Mentor B: لأن أكاونت.
Mentor B: مش.
Mentor B: تاني، فاهم.
Mentor B: لو كان فيش مشكلة.
Mentor B: المشكلة تقنية بسيطة جدا نتغلب.
Mentor B: مش.
Mentor B: أوكي يلا.
Mentor B: مع السلامة.
Mentor B: يعني ما تقفلوش على طول.
Mentor B: يعني استنوا روكوكوبي.
Mentor B: هبعته جوجل ميد بقى.
Mentor B: ماشي.
Mentor B: أم تمام يا جماعة واللي بعت لينك فرشات
Mentor B: إنه إسنادا و مشاة
Mentor B: معادل
Mentor B: فرنش
Mentor B: نظام فضل شغل غير عادي
Mentor B: نامي. أوكي نافل عينيك.